One of the stories that stands out in terms
of police brutality from the last week or
10 days of protests is the video of 75 year
old Martin Guggi know being shoved down to
the ground by two Buffalo police officers.
Buffalo, New York, hitting his head so hard
that he actually started bleeding from his
right ear, seemingly knocked unconscious when
it happened.
The two officers involved in that incident
have been charged with second degree assault
after they were filmed knocking Gargano over
these two officers, a 39 year old, Aaron Tur
golf ski, and 32 year old Robert McCabe.
They've both pleaded not guilty and they've
both been suspended without pay.
And this incident led to the resignations
of dozens of Buffalo police officers.
No, no, no.
Not because they are protesting what these
two officers did, because they are defending
what the two officers did in shoving Martin
Gugino Guggi.
No.
And now Donald Trump is actually attacking.
Wait for it.
The 75 year old guy who was put into critical
condition by the officers.
The Daily Beast reports that as of Monday
afternoon, Guggi Snow had been upgraded from
critical to serious, but stable.
And Donald Trump yesterday spread a completely
baseless conspiracy theory that Googie Snow
was some part of an TIFA setup of the police
officers, a planned provocation of some kind.
This is something that's been alleged by Donald
Trump's latest favorite propaganda outlet.
Oh, and Donald Trump tweeting yesterday, quote,
Buffalo protesters shoved by police could
be an anti fur provocateur.
Seventy five year old Martin Guggi Snow was
pushed away after appearing to scan police
communications in order to black out their
equipment.
Oh, when I watched.
He fell harder than was pushed.
Was aiming scanner.
Could be a setup.
Now, a lot of the debate is over whether this
could be true rather than the insanity of
Donald Trump.
The president even tweeting something like
this, but just to do our thorough due diligence.
Here's the story Trump is referring to from
O.J.
And take a look and you'll be able to tell
that Trump is just completely, uncritically
falling for obvious agitprop style propaganda.
Take a look at reports.
Find a protest.
Sara first by Buffalo Police was appearing
to use common and TFR tactics when America's
Christian rose looks into the matter.
A new report finds the latest.
Sentience of the Buffalo police departments
could be a result of a false flag provocation
by far left group antifa.
So I'm cutting the video there because we'll
be monetized if we show the actual footage
of Guggi, you know, being knocked down.
But you get the idea of the story on.
And so I need you to understand that this
is a completely baseless conspiracy.
It was even suggested that Lugano again came
equipped with some kind of fake blood dispenser
and that what appears to be Guggi, no bleeding
from his ear is actually not.
Imagine how absurd this is.
He was an anti foot plant who tricked police
into pushing him so he could slam his own
head into the pavement and put himself in
the hospital for a week.
What a big win for the protesters right now.
In contrast, Donald Trump is attacking an
elderly man who was assaulted by police.
And yet he has said nothing about the KKK
member who drove into a crowd of protesters
a few days ago.
Now, you might hear me say that and you might
be wondering.
KKK.
What are you talking about, David?
I didn't hear about that.
And that's exactly part of the problem.
You might not even have heard of this story,
but in Hanover, Virginia.
Thirty six year old Harry Rogers was arrested
after he drove his truck into a crowd of protesters.
And it has now been admitted that he is a
known leader of the Ku Klux Klan and a disseminator
of what is considered or called a Confederate
ideology.
Trump has said nothing about that, but is
defending police in one of the most brutal
anecdotes of these protesters, while suggesting
that the victim, a 75 year old peace activist,
might be an anti for plant equipped with surreptitious
police monitoring technology.
So what I would like to see Republicans come
out and say is not whether they believe Trump's
conspiracy theory, the O.J. and conspiracy
theory.
I would like them to come out and say that
merely getting involved in this type of thing
is an absolute atrocity for a president to
do, because a lot of the debate, sadly, is
about whether Martin Guggi know might be a
provocateur, whether Martin Guggi know might
have brought a fake blood device of some kind.
The real issue is that the president is even
involved in this absolute gutter trash.
And the effect of all of this is that it just
continues to divide the country.
If Trump can divide the country about such
an obvious, clear cut case of police brutality
by sowing doubt and uncertainty, by amplifying
a story from O.J., and he is preventing people
from coming together about anything like if
people can't come together about this incident,
then the country can be divided about almost
anything.
And we have to remind ourselves that this
is the president of the United States who
is saying these things and participating in
this stuff.
This is what we would normally expect to see
people like Alex Jones tweeting about.
And it's the president who's tweeting about
it.
How does he have millions, tens of millions
of supporters still?
And at a certain point, you know, I did this
segment a couple, maybe a year a little more
ago called We have to accept that there's
a lot of stupid people in the segment clearly
resonated and did very, very well, although
some people took offense to it.
We have to understand that this says something
really horrifying about our country, that
Donald Trump can be saying these things and
doing these things and maintaining the support
of tens of millions of people despite tweeting
such obvious agit trash, as I like to call
it.
We're going to continue following this on
The David Pakman Show Instagram page, which
is David Pakman show on Instagram.
Also, follow me on Instagram at David Pakman.
I think tomorrow or the next day, we're going
to have a video of me harvesting my one strawberry
from my garden and a single leaf with mint
and eating it, preparing it in a gourmet fashion.
That's on my personal Instagram David Pakman.
Follow the show on Instagram for more on this
story at
David Pakman